-He is a talented author
and Booker Prize finalist
whose new book,
"Filthy Animals,"
was published today.
Please welcome to the show
Brandon Taylor.
How are you, Brandon?
-Oh, great.
Thanks for having me.
-I am thrilled to have you.
Now, your first novel
is being adapted into a film.
You're writing the screenplay.
And now your second book
is out today,
and you're here to promote it.
Where have you ended up
insofar as what you predicted
going into your writing career?
-Well, the very outer reaches
of the solar system,
I would say.
[ Both laugh ]
With my first book,
I thought, "Okay.
Five people will read this,
four of which
are my family members maybe
and maybe that one friend
who shows up to everything
despite there not being
a thing to show up to."
But, I mean, I've just been
blown away by the way
that readers have, you know,
taken me in
and the way that they've loved
this book, and, yeah.
So all of my expectations met,
exceeded even.
-So, you -- before you got your
MFA -- I'm fascinated by this --
you were a student biochemist.
And I'm wondering
if you completely left
that learning behind
or if you brought along
some of your scientific
background with you
when you started
writing fiction.
-I think science is a lot like
a cult, in that
once you are indoctrinated,
you never quite
get out of that mind-set.
I think once you're trained
as a scientist,
you're a scientist forever.
And, yeah.
And so there are many, many ways
in which my scientific training
influences my writing,
though I guess the most obvious
of which is that science
teaches you how to, like,
do a very strenuous long-term
project, the outcome of which
is very uncertain, and, like,
that is just writing, honestly.
-You -- I've read that you enjoy
putting your work
in academic settings,
and one of the reasons is,
there was not a lot
of representation when you
read books
that took places there.
I should say you never really
saw yourself in any of those.
-Yeah. I mean, I --
You know like many people,
I spent most of my life
on a campus.
And I spent a lot of time
in academia,
and I love reading about
academia.
There's just something about
those professors
getting up to hijinks that I
just cannot get enough of.
But, yeah, you're right.
Like, time and again,
when I read those books,
I always felt like,
"Well, there are no Black people
in these books.
There are no queer people
in these books."
And yet there are Black, queer
people on campus,
as I am one of them,
and so when I started writing
my first stories,
it just made sense
that I would write about
a setting that I was
deeply familiar with,
and I felt like I was getting
to correct the record
a little bit by writing myself
and people like me
into those stories.
-So, two of the characters
are dancers in the book.
And it is written about
so beautifully
that I was wondering
if you yourself
had a background in dance.
-Only as, like, an intense
superfan and spectator.
I always wanted
to be a dancer as a child,
but my mom always
forbade me from it
because she thought
it would make my gay.
But then, like,
I turned out to be gay anyway...
[ Laughter ]
...and so if it I could
go back in time, I would be
like, "Just let him dance.
It's gonna be --
It's gonna be fine."
But, no, a lot of the dance
in the book just comes from
really loving dance
and being a dance enthusiast
and reading everything
I possibly could about it
to find out, you know,
like, "What are dancers like?"
And turns out
they're like the rest of us --
anxious, petty,
competitive, nervous.
-Were there books --
You mention that you read a lot.
You read
when you were very young.
Is that true, as well?
-Yeah.
Oh, yeah.
I was a compulsive reader.
Reading everything
I could get my hands on.
-And what was it
that you could get your hands on
when you were young?
What were the books that
influenced you,
or I should say,
were the first things
that influenced you?
-Yeah, so I --
The first books that I read
as, like, a young child
were romance novels.
Because my aunt was
the only person in my family
who was really a big reader.
And so I was reading
the books at hand,
and the books at hand
were these like, you know,
$2 bodice-rippers from the
grocery store and from Walmart.
But, to me, they were, you know,
the pinnacle of literature.
And to this day,
I still have a real
sort of fondness
for romance novels.
-You know, I didn't realize
exactly how intense the feedback
you get in writers workshops
is from your fellow writers.
Do you find that helpful,
or, on an ego level,
is it just the most brutal thing
in the world?
-I think both.
You know, there's always a --
there's always a little nugget
of something helpful,
I think, in every
little bit of feedback.
But sometimes you've got
to really rummage around
inside of it
to find the part that's helpful.
But it was,
I mean, incredibly brutal.
I mean, people talking about
your work for two hours,
taking it apart
on the molecular level almost,
and you weren't allowed
to talk back.
So it was just like
getting kicked in the teeth
over and over again, you know,
in the place
where you're most sensitive --
your art.
-Oh, so you're not allowed
to respond at all
as you're getting
real-time criticism
from your fellow writers?
-So this is one thing that's,
like, changing in sort of
creative-writing programs
across the country,
but when I did my MFA,
we were not allowed to respond.
And, I mean, my first workshop
teacher even told us
not to even look at the person
as we were talking
about their work.
[ Laughter ]
Like it was very --
It was very hostile
and confrontational.
-You also -- You have a robust
Twitter presence.
Do you enjoy --
What is the thing you most enjoy
using Twitter for?
-Um...
Many -- Sowing chaos, of course,
like everyone else.
I think the thing that I love
most about Twitter is that you
can find a fandom or a community
based around almost anything.
Like, I've recently gotten very
into like niche pottery Twitter.
That's a real fun place
to lurk around.
And so I just think that Twitter
is full of these interesting
ready-made communities,
but sometimes it goes
real dark real fast.
-I want to give you credit.
because "Mare of Easttown,"
which was a show you and I
both were watching.
You called it.
You called the twist weeks out.
-Yes.
I felt very smug about it.
I felt very proud.
I will say that the day before
the finale, I went to a barbecue
with some friends,
and we were swapping theories,
as one does,
and I shared my theory,
and all my friends were like,
"No, no,
I don't think that's it.
I don't think -- No, because
how would this have happened?"
And I was like,
"No, I think it's it."
And then, when it happened, I,
of course, texted all of them
very smugly...
[ Laughter ]
...to let them know
that I had, in fact,
seen it with my third eye,
my second sight. Yes.
-You were like,
"I think the killer
is gonna look like a kid
from Los Angeles."
[ Laughter ]
Have you watched
"Tiny Secret Whispers" yourself?
-Oh, yeah.
I'm a big fan.
I'm a super fan.
I've got a group chat.
-I mean, did you think --
All in all,
did you think it paid off?
-Yes.
I think that
there was a great arc.
I think the first couple
episodes, real slow.
But then the titration
of information at the end...
-Yeah.
-Exquisite.
-I mean, I think you said it
better than anyone has.
[ Laughter ]
Hey, thank you so much
for being here.
Congratulations on your book.
It's wonderful.
-Thanks so much.